hello everyone and welcome to a game a
lot of you have requested it's holidays
a fedora vs. Peruvian grandmaster jorge
quarry and it's from the who win matches
in netherlands so like every year to
classical matches will be played the
first matches of it as a ferocious vs
4head korean the second one is the
antimony versus agencia abdul malik it's
90 90 minutes per player for 40 moves
then you get a 30 additional more moves
and you get 30 seconds increment from
the beginning of the game so why have a
lot of you requested this game let's
let's find out
Alisa with the white pieces opens with E
for okay c5 we have the Sicilian defense
Knight to f3 with East 6 and d4 so
pretty standard stuff see captures
Knight captures and a6 now we've Bishop
to d3 by Alireza
in the d6 now with castles and Knight to
f6 Knight to c3 just continuing
development Bishop to e7 black does the
same and I'll keep the h1 as this
diagonal is now open you don't want to
push f4 before playing King to h1 always
a useful move Knights the c6 and now
Knight the b3 avoiding trades with
castles by Corey and now a for
preventing b5 with b6 now if white
pushes a5 black can also push b5 + f4
now now as planned since King each one
was played and now Bishop the b7 so also
continued development Queen to f3 and
night to be for going after the bishop
on d3 which will get rid of whites and
bishop pair and here there is one game
where night the d4 was played but here
we have Queen to h3 and it is a new move
by Alireza so already has moved 13 we
have a completely new game
Corey grabs one of the bishops with
Knight captures on d3
see captures on d3 and now rook the c8
so Corey has the bishop pair now he has
a nice open file for his rook
whereas ali reza will try to create some
chances on the King side with Knight d4
and rook to e8 preparing to bring the
bishop over to f8 push g6 get the best
board over to g7 with Bishop to e3
now preparing to bring the final Rock
entire game and bash of the f8 by Corey
rook 8d 1 and G 6 as s planned and here
all of whites pieces are perfectly
developed you don't really have an
opportunity to improve the position of
any of the pieces so the time to strike
is now and here are there is a place f5
and okay he captures an f5 and now
before recapturing Bishop to g5 now
saying okay if you capture then both my
rook and the bishop are attacking the
knight so you'll just lose the piece
so first Bishop to g7 by Corey and now
he captures an f5 recapturing now and
Queen to d7 saying okay if you capture
then we trade Queens and you cannot you
cannot grab upon for example if you play
something like captures and g6 black
might grab a queen but the problem is
after Queen captures now whatever you
play doesn't really work for example you
could play G captures on f7 or something
with check King captures on f7 and now
you cannot recapture the Queen because
of the pin under on the jeep on so after
this Queen to d7 moved that's that's not
really the idea behind it but still G
captures on f5 perhaps can be played
although very unlikely
so Queen to h4 by ali reza now as the
Queen moved now just threatening Queen
Bishop captures on f6 which would win a
piece so nice to h5 and here now f6 this
was already this plan the bishop is now
under attack and instead of moving the
base right away h6 first pushing white
special back with Bishop back to d2 and
now Knight captures on f6 grabbing that
pawn which is odd because you can just
give up the rook for two pieces but this
is where the game begins
it starts to be really fun so rook
captures on f6 and here what do you play
well Corey plate rook captures on c3
which is a very nice idea although there
is this g5 move which forces white now
you're either losing the Queen own or or
black will just recapture the rook so
you have to go Bishop captures captures
captures and now after Queen to e7
you will just well you will just be
of the trade Queens black-white has to
play rook f5 and the new trade Queens
because if rook the f1 then you just
capture you can just capture here it's
not a problem
Queen or rook captures doesn't really
matter but she captures and you are
unable to capture back because of mate
on the back rank check block and the
mate
so g5 was definitely an interesting idea
but it requires a lot of precise
calculation and Corey found an even more
interesting line although a bit a bit
different rook captures on c3 and rook
captures on c3 is just removing the
defender of the rook on d1 so if you're
wondering why would we remove the
defender of the rook on d1 it's not like
broken d1 is under attack
well the fact of the matter is that the
rook on d1 is under attack only it's
very hard to see it so rook captures on
c3 we have B captures on c3 and now
Bishop captures on f6 first getting the
Queen away from the g4 square while
capturing a rook Queen captures on f6
and then now Bishop captures and g2 with
check and now you see how the rook on d1
is under attack this is what chorus plan
was with King captures and g2 and now
Queen to g4 with check King to f2 and
now Queen captures on d1 so here it's a
queen and rook against the Queen night
and bishop but until the Knights and
Bishop can get you know some good
squares the Queen and rook are somewhat
easier to play so Bishop captures on h6
this is the best where you could
possibly hope for is it threatens mate
in one this is what has a place and now
Queen e1 check we reach the position
from the thumbnail so what happens now
King to g2
there are no more checks in the position
now the night covers this Square and the
pawn covers this course so you you could
end it the bishop of course covers the D
2 square so you don't really have a good
check and rookie to check it doesn't
really work white will just move the
King King h3 so Queen to e5 you have to
prevent mate about also offering a queen
trade so oh it is a declines the trade
we have Queen to f3 if you accept the
trade characters captures then I
is under attack who goes here attacks
the night and once black pushes f5 gets
his King into the position starts
pushing all of this all of these pawns
he will have a good good play and what
did the rook against the bishop in the
night so Queen back to f3 by ali reza
and now b 5 with a captures a captures
and now worshipped f4 pushing the Queen
back also pressuring the d6 pawn queen
to c5 and now Queen to c6 now it's all
arrays of who offers the Queen trade
saying that okay you're this exponent
will be with your b4 b5 one will be weak
so I don't mind trading Queens here and
here you you should go for rook to see
it it's the best defensive idea for
Corey goes for rook to e to with check
the idea being that the knight cannot
capture because Queen Queen captures
Queen so keep the g3 and now rook the e1
which trades pawns here with Queen
captures on d6 by Allah Reza and now
Queen captures on c3 with Knight back to
f3 attacking the rook and rook back to a
e8 so here we get a very interesting
position where what would you play in
this position for ali reza feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
winning idea for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
such a nice centralizing move and for
those of you who just want to enjoy a
show Ali Reza played Queen to d7 he went
for the double attack against the rook
and the pawn which ones upon but there
is the stronger Bishop to e5 which
forces black to give up the rook if you
don't give up the rook White was simply
force you to give up the rook if you
move the Queen Queen b3 just Queen f6
threatens mate and now you have to give
up the rook captures now you're first
you're gonna go Queen d8 check King
moves the g7 Knight captures on e5 your
d3 pawn is now nicely protected by the
Queen and the night so you can if f6 you
can move the knight so it's not a
problem you will not be losing any
points and here of course what white
would just be winning as his upper piece
but ali reza went for a different line
Queen to d7 okay it still wins the b5
pawn we have Queen to c8 and now comes
Queen captures on b5 with f6 by black
and now H for not allowing g5
Queens the e6 and now d4 Alireza starts
pushing his passport rook to b8 you
don't want to allow the past point
across the d5 square and Queen to a5
attacking the rook with rook the d7 and
now Queen to a a to check King to g7 and
now Queen to b8 so just waiting to see
what black will do Queen back to e7 and
now Bishop back to see one we've came to
h7 and now Bishop back to d2 again
Rema nuvaring the bishop to the best
possible square Queen to f7 and now
Bishop to b4 finally the Queen moved
from the control of the e7 square and
now you have to be very careful we have
King to g7 and now Bishop to d6 taking
away even more squares from blacks
pieces and here best idea for black is
Ruby 7 after the Queen moves Ruby 3 and
you will look for chances there may be
if the if the White Queen abandons this
diagonal maybe you can get somehow Queen
to d5 in and then white will have to
worry about defending but Corey went
Queen to ecigs and this just allows our
eyes a bit too much but it's very hard
to see why okay everyone sees a queen to
f8 check that's not the problem that is
what our is a plate Queen to f8 check
with King to h7 but the next move is to
move that really that's really just a
beauty so feel free to pause the video
and try to find the move Corey missed
when he played Quinta e6 well I give you
a couple of seconds so for those of you
who are able to do it congratulations
I'm finding it's the same centralizing
move that you've already found it's a
Bishop to g5 and for those of you who
just want to enjoy it show there it is
and now there is no defense the threat
is very simple the thread is a knight
the g5 and you don't have a good reply
to this if Knight to g5 it's just game
over you have to capture and then Queen
to h8 will be made it's the same if you
capture the bishop if you capture the
bishop it's even worse it's not g5 its
mate in one
so not possible and if loop to f7
just attacking the Queen not allowing
getting captures on f6 it's still Knight
to g5 just F captures and now Queen a
trade is made so not possible to
get out of this one Cory tried with g5
he created an outpost here on g6 for his
King but our resume h5 and it was in
this position
unmoor 51 that ali reza furiosa resigned
the game because now nothing really
changes it's the same if F captures here
then just Knight captures and g5 is mate
in one because the pawn now also covers
the g6 where and if you don't if you
play whatever rogue g7 then you just
trade down into a completely winning
endgame Queen captures on f6 you just
eliminate this pawn Queen captures
Bishop captures and now you're gonna win
this point you will be 2 points up with
a with a knight and Bishop against the
rook is of course completely winning
so after h5 Corey resigned the game and
this is a four games have already been
played Alvarez at 1/3 and Corey one-one
but there are still two more games to be
played it's a six-game match so Corey
definitely has an opportunity to bounce
back in the match so we'll see how it
goes
so once again that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would just like to say
that I have been checking up on your
soccer suggestions and that I have
narrowed it down the five of them so I
will very very soon do a poll where you
will be able to vote on the next big
saga and then we'll just take it from
there
I would also like to thank la guerra law
and Jason Bryn for Jones for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - my previous videos Aaron
think oh for watching and I will see
soon continuing or checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and well hopefully
we'll get our next big saga starting
soon so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of a day